- [Narrator] These two
brilliantly colored monkeys
are the pride of their
native country, Brazil.
This is the Golden Lion Tamarin.
(soft music)
The Golden Lion Tamarin's
signature feature
is its silky reddish gold coat.
Its long mane frames its bare face,
thus the feline namesake.
These little guys love
to eat fruits, insects
and small invertebrates.
And they'll use their long thin fingers
to hunt for their prey in narrow spaces.
They spend their lives
swinging in the trees
of Brazil's southeastern coastal forests.
In the 1970s, only a couple
hundred were left in the wild
due to collection for the
pet trade and habitat loss.
While still endangered today,
conservation efforts around the world
have boosted their population.
The Golden Lion Tamarin has
become a national symbol
in Brazil, even appearing
on the country's money.
This is the Golden Lion Tamarin.